call of duty could be coming to the
switch in the future and there's a huge
battlefield petition that seems to be
getting larger
speaking to cnbc microsoft president
brad smith reiterated microsoft's
potential acquisition of activision
blizzard will not stop the company's
games from appearing on rival hardware
and after microsoft recently issued a
statement that suggested more activision
blizzard games could be coming to switch
smith more explicitly noted that may
include call of duty during the
interview he said quote we'd like to
bring it to nintendo devices we'd like
to bring the other popular titles that
activision blizzard has and ensure that
they continue to be available on
playstation that they become available
on nintendo the last call of duty title
to release on a nintendo console was
call of duty ghosts for the wii u which
was released in 2013. a number of call
of duty games have been released on
nintendo consoles over the years but
have never found as much success
compared to playstation and xbox and
weird fact about me the very first call
of duty i played was call of duty 3 on
the wii and then i got 4 on the 360 and
i never looked back i'm not sure i would
ever play a call of duty on a nintendo
device again but let me know if you're
interested on like a war zone on the uh
on the switch or something like that let
me know in the comments
and sticking with call of duty players
will soon be able to play as an armored
titan with season 2 of warzone and
vanguard the new season's update is
already available for download and while
the seasonal content doesn't go live
until february 14th players can now see
a preview of a new attack on titan armor
titan operator skin call of duty
recently had an attack on titan
crossover in season 1 reloaded this
inaugural bundle is still available in
the shop for 2 400 cod points or 20
bucks the details of this new armor
titan bundle have not been revealed but
it should be released sometime in season
two and while there was some community
criticism for the last bundle just being
a skin put on the operator daniel in a
survey corpse outfit this roland
operator looks like an actual titan
but in other shooter news a change.org
petition demanding that players be
allowed to refund battlefield 2042 now
has over
120 000 signatures the petition which
started on february 2nd calls ea's
release of the latest battlefield title
a quote mockery of every customer who
purchased this video game with the goal
of showing just how many people want
full refunds the petition's creator
satoshi nakamoto suggested a
class-action lawsuit could be filed
although it's unclear whether such a
case would have any chance of succeeding
at the time of this recording ea has
provided no indication that it plans to
offer refunds nor is there any sign of
this petition having an effect outside
of standardized systems such as steam's
refund policy publishers offering
refunds on games is an extremely
uncommon practice with one notable
recent exception being cyberpunk 2077.
many fans of the battlefield franchise
have been disappointed by battlefield
2042 and since its launch this past
november the game has been plagued by
numerous bugs which have kept developer
dice busy sorting them out however the
team has been so busy squashing the
game's bugs that it hasn't been able to
focus on extra content for the game
recently dice delayed the game's first
season which was supposed to add a new
map and specialist to this summer so be
honest with me did you sign that
petition
now be extra honest with me did you sign
that petition knowing you don't have a
copy of the game you just saw a report
and wanted to be a part of it or be a
troll
let me know in the comments
[Music]
you